The change in amino acid 415 from a glycine
to a cystein, significantly affects the way the collagen
protein forms a triple helix, which significantly reduces the
structural integrity of bones. Now without a fully functioning collagen
protein, you're at a much higher risk for bone
fractures. For example, there was an individual, a real person
that had the mutation, the very mutation we just
got done talking about. That person suffered more than 270
bone fractures over a period of 16 years that resulted in severe skeletal
deformity. Now, remember though, not everyone with
Osteogenesis Imperfecta has a mutation that severe.